cuando se produce un ataque de migraña
los medicamentos de rescate pueden
ayudar a aliviar el dolor veamos qué
ocurre en el cerebro durante un ataque y
Cómo pueden afectar los distintos
medicamentos a este
proceso durante un ataque su sistema
nervioso se activa en exceso estimula
las fibras de dolor del nervio trigémino
y los vasos sanguíneos de las meninges
que son los tejidos que rodean el
exterior del
encéfalo cuando se estimulan las fibras
del dolor liberan el péptido relacionado
con el gen de la calcitonina que se
abrevia como cgrp por sus siglas en
inglés así como otros mensajeros
químicos el cgrp hace que los vasos
sanguíneos se dilaten lo que provoca un
dolor
palpitante el cgrp también activa las
células inmunitarias como los mastocitos
y los gliocitos estas liberan citocinas
que caus causan inflamación
local el cgrp también sensibiliza los
nervios trigémino que intervienen en el
envío de Señales al tronco encefálico y
al resto del cerebro lo que provoca más
dolor y otros
síntomas la serotonina otro
neurotransmisor puede realizar muchas
funciones a través de receptores que se
encuentran en la superficie de distintos
tipos de
células durante una crisis de migraña la
serotonina se une a los receptores 1 B 1
d y 1 F de los nervios trigémino lo que
a su vez Ordena los nervios que bloqueen
la producción de
cgrp con menor
cgrp hay menos Dolor e inflamación en
las meninges y el resto del
cerebro la serotonina también calma la
migraña al activar los receptores 1 b y
1d de los vasos sanguíneos que evitan su
inflamación
dolorosa el objetivo de los medicamentos
para la migraña es detener el ataque
interrumpiendo los procesos químicos que
lo
causan los medicamentos llamados
triptanos pueden imitar a la serotonina
y unirse a sus receptores 1 b y 1 d de
los nervios trigémino y los vasos
sanguíneos los triptanos reducen la
cantidad de cgrp y contraen los vasos
sanguíneos inflamados lo que resulta en
una reducción del dolor y la inflamación
durante un ataque de migraña pero como
el receptor de serotonina 1b que provoca
la constricción de los vasos sanguíneos
también se encuentra en todo el cuerpo
los triptanos también pueden causar
sobrecarga cardíaca hipertensión
arterial y accidente cerebrovascular en
consecuencia los triptanos deben
utilizarse con precaución en personas
con riesgos cardiovasculares importantes
hay siete triptanos diferentes y varian
en cuanto a la rapidez con que actúan y
la duración de su efecto la rapidez con
la que actúan también depende de si se
administra an en forma de píldora
aerosol nasal o
inyección los nuevos medicamentos de
rescate no constriñen los vasos
sanguíneos y no presentan los riesgos de
los triptanos por ejemplo los heantes
son un grupo de pequeñas moléculas que
minimizan el dolor de la migraña
bloqueando la unión del cgrp con sus
receptores principalmente en las
terminaciones nerviosas el lasmiditan es
el primero de un grupo diferente de
pequeñas moléculas denominadas dianos el
lasmiditan funciona de forma similar a
un triptano salvo que solo activa los
receptores de serotonina 1f que se
localizan principalmente en los nervios
trigémino no en los vasos sanguíneos el
lasmiditan puede causar somnolencia por
lo que debe evitarse conducir durante
las 8 horas siguientes a su toma los
cornes suelos como la dhe activan varios
receptores de serotonina como los
triptanos el cornezuelo dura más que los
triptanos pero tarda más en actuar y es
más difícil que penetre en el
organismo puede ser eficaz pero al igual
que los triptanos provoca el
estrechamiento de los vasos sanguíneos
lo que lo hace peligroso para los
pacientes de edad avanzada en particular
los que presentan riesgos
cardiovasculares las prostaglandinas son
sustancias químicas del organismo que
pueden provocar la inflamación de los
vasos sanguíneos dentro y alrededor del
cerebro también pueden aumentar la
inflamación y la sensibilidad del
organismo al dolor las enzimas
ciclooxigenasas denominadas Cox 1 y Cox
2 son fundamentales en la producción de
prostaglandinas los antiinflamatorios no
esteroideos o aine como el ibuprofeno y
la Aspirina bloquean las enzimas coxs y
por tanto la producción de plag landinas
Y el dolor el aine celecoxib tiene menos
probabilidades de provocar efectos
secundarios gastrointestinales como
náuseas ardor de estómago y úlceras que
otros aine ya que solo bloquea las
enzimas cox2 otro medicamento de rescate
llamado butal vital es un tipo de
barbitúrico El butal vital suele
combinarse con cafeína Paracetamol o
aspirina para tratar la migraña pero el
butal vital puede ser adictivo y
provocar muchos efectos secundarios como
malestar estomacal vómitos temblores
mareos
somnolencia problemas para dormir y
sequedad en la boca tomar un medicamento
de rescate en cuanto aparecen los
síntomas es importante para evitar
rápidamente una crisis de migraña y
reducir el riesgo de que la enfermedad
se vuelva Crónica pero el uso excesivo
de medicamentos de rescate entraña un
peligro evita utilizar el Paracetamol y
los aine más de 14 días al
mes y evita utilizar triptanos butal
vital o cornezuelo más de 9 días al mes
el uso frecuente de estos medicamentos
puede provocar otro tipo de cefalea
denominada se falea por abuso de
medicación la eficacia de los
medicamentos de rescate es diferente
para cada persona encontrar los más
adecuados implica ensayo y error algunos
medicamentos pueden ser más eficaces
cuando se utilizan en combinación por
ejemplo los triptanos los jeant y los
tianes pueden tomarse con
aine Añadir un neuromodulador someterse
a bloqueos nerviosos o realizar cambios
en el estilo de vida también puede
ayudar a controlar los síntomas de la
migraña Para más información acerca del
tratamiento de la migraña consulte a su
médico